hello youtube this is CZ speaking with
the release of the new Death Note movie
on Netflix okay
okay I'm not gonna keep up that voice
for the entire video but anyway here are
the things you missed in Death Note the
very first episode of things you missed
was an episode on the trailer for this
movie and now it's finally been released
one of the biggest complaints I saw
about this movie on Twitter was the lack
of the iconic potato chip scene however
it may have actually been referenced in
a small way at a couple of different
points in the film the Mia Sutton is
seen eating some potato chips in lights
of room then he goes over to the desk
and it's covered in crumbs so maybe the
scene did take place off camera so to
speak did anyone else think when light
got caught with the homework pages that
it was strange that she found those but
not the death note I just imagine her
thought process you may have this book
that's capable of killing thousands of
people and that's fine but boy if you
cheat in my class I will mess you up
it's even more ridiculous considering
that there have actually been instances
of kids getting in trouble for having
fake death notes and schools before I
attempted to read each page of the death
note but motion blur and Netflix is
streaming quality made it kind of hard
but here's what I picked up this page
says something about suicide and scarlet
fever light Turner is not the first one
to have the death note and all the
previous pages and names are already in
there some of them were historical
figures and others just seem to be names
this guy Jean shay-bo was a Canadian
legislator in the 1800s Mike hell
clapper read a was a French General in
the 1700s
Charles Adrienne Murad a it was a
nobleman in Europe and I believe the
name is also French in fact it seems
that the death note spent quite a lot of
time in France the next page contains
Louie's Shibu Michel clapper read a
again with something else crossed out
and Andre masse arena a French military
commander so I'm thinking one of lights'
predecessors used the Death Note as a
political weapon in ancient France can
you say spin off before we continue I
need to set the record straight on this
Apple thing for some reason in this
movie Luke does not eat the center of
the Apple if you're a Death Note fan you
know that apple cores are a myth they
don't exist it's all just Apple don't
believe me let me demonstrate
[Music]
another thing I found strange nobody
questions the destroyed classroom this
seems like a bigger deal than helping
some kids cheat on their tests but it
never comes up again his light goes to
the window some text reading the world
is written on the wall is that because
it's a classroom and classrooms have
maps of the world yes but could it also
be a reference to the song title of the
first opie of Death Note probably not in
this movie light lives with his dad so
unfortunately we do not get to see mrs.
Yagami or siyou we actually find out
that light's mom was killed I had
assumed that it was earlier in his life
but she's still around in this picture
on light sixteenth birthday so it must
be very recent now in the anime and
manga the gods of death come from the
Shinigami realm which is not seen in any
of the films unless you count the real
lights but those are just the anime cut
down into the length of a film so that
should not count although we don't see
the Shinigami realm in this movie that
doesn't mean it doesn't exist
I noticed rule 65 in the notebook makes
reference to the Shinigami realm it
would also appear that the 19 day rule
is still in effect if you aren't
familiar with it it allows you to write
the cause of death before the name so
long as you do fill in the name within
19 days also the four hundred and ninety
days you get to maintain ownership of
the Death Note without possessing it has
been shortened to seven in this movie
and for no good reason because it never
comes up in the scene light tries to get
Mia to Syriac by having her touch the
notebook which works in the anime but
not in this movie apparently so what I'm
wondering is where did he get the idea
to try that did light watch the anime or
read the manga do those things exist in
the world of this movie kind of the
Brody hostage situation takes place in
Little Tokyo in Seattle which is just a
little reference to Japan and there are
a few in this film like how light tries
to make it seem like he is in Japan by
adopting the kita moniker again did he
watch the anime and making many of his
early killings in Japan we were gonna
start getting into spoilers for the
anime and
movie now this is your final warning
remember in my initial video how I
speculated that Mia Sutton was the US
version of meesa meesa well Mia has an
eye on her window which is interesting
considering that mousse obtains the
Shinigami eyes and the manga and she's
basically the eyes of Keira in this
movie there are no Shinigami eyes but
she does at times play the hand of Keira
which is what Mika me does in the manga
the song that watt said he sings to Elle
is from The Wizard of odds it plays when
they skipped through the flowers towards
Emerald City I'll talk more about the
significance of flowers in this Death
Note movie later in this video
detective Turner has a list of murders
that he suspects to be key to murders in
his office some of them are kind of
funny and there are very few heart
attacks compared to Light Yagami here
are a few examples eaten by thylacine
attacked by bull shark crushed by
crystal chandelier falling to death
electrocuted while playing guitar in the
bath there were a few interesting things
that Elle has one of which is a golden
apple the other appears to be a puzzle
cube type thing if Mia's Sutton is a
combination of Mesa and Myka me maybe L
is a combination of Elle and near the
Lind L tailor scene is skipped over in
favor of L directly confronting light he
claims I shall be meeting you face to
face very shortly which he does in a
really short scene light notices this
guy following him who is basically a
penber his name in this movie is Raymond
young in the anime light goes on a date
with his classmate Yuri to space world
which is a Japanese amusement park in an
attempt to out the identity of rape
ember on the bus in this movie he takes
Mia on a date to an attraction on Pier
57 where they address how the stalker
should be dealt with so I guess it's
supposed to be the same scene that's not
how L holds a phone this is how Ella
holds a phone it seems strange that some
of his other mannerisms from the anime
carried over to Stanfield's l but not
others
I guess whatta T is just w's full name
of this movie light right Swati in the
Death Note and it works in the manga his
real name is quill issue Emmy this is
probably my favorite entry in the Death
Note this guy's name is Abdul asswad and
the cause of death eats a grenade eats a
grenade at this point I don't understand
why it light doesn't just burn the page
himself that would be the first thing I
would do if you
noticed this movie is nowhere near as
smart as its Japanese counterpart if you
haven't seen those movies I would highly
recommend you check out Death Note and
Death Note 2 the last name I can't say
the same for the spin-off sequel l
changed the world this video is not
sponsored both the first and last major
Kira killings happen in front of a
florist when Mia dies she lands right on
this bed of flowers leading me to
believe that the flowers are somehow
representative of death if flowers are
death then butterflies are an agent of
death or a spreader of death we see
butterflies constantly being associated
with Mia in her room in her locker
a butterfly balloon hovering next to her
when she's reunited with light close to
the end if you notice any other
references let me know in the comments
if you want to have your very own death
note leave a like on this video tomorrow
the 27th we're doing a new dead stream
at 2 p.m. Pacific that's 5 p.m. Eastern
10:00 p.m. British summer time we would
love to have you join us it'll be right
here on C's world if you're new to the
channel I'm a filmmaker I make horror I
talk about horror so if you like or be
sure to subscribe to the channel for new
Horrors every week bring that death Bell
for notifications and I'll see you
tomorrow in the dead stream assuming we
both survive